passée la crise du coronavirus à quoi
ressemblera le monde d'après vous êtes
nombreux à vous poser la question
emmanuel macron en tout cas l'a laissé
entendre lors de sa dernière allocution
l'économie de sortir a profondément
changé de cette épidémie souveraineté
indépendance autonomie
le président at il changé de logiciel
vers quel modèle économique se
dirige-t-on on voit cela tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques toujours via skype et ce sera
encore le cas pendant toute la durée de
ce confinement jacques oui tout à fait
jusqu'au 11 mai on l'espère et alors
jacques à comment se dessine donc ce
monde d'après cas évoqués emmanuel
macron et bien ses fans il faut tout
d'abord comprendre que la france et son
économie vont sortir très affaibli de
cette crise sanitaire à bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie nous parle
d'un recul de 8% du produit intérieur
brut
gérald darmanin le ministre du budget
prévoit quant à lui un déficit public de
près de 9% de ce même pib c'est dire
l'importance du choc
or ces deux ministres pêche très
probablement encore par optimisme alors
jacques dans quelle mesure justement
est-ce trop optimistes et bien si vous
voulez stéphanie les estimations de
l'insee et de la banque de france sur
lesquelles s'appuient en particulier
bruno le maire pour deux mois de
confinement se base sur une contraction
de l'économie d'environ 6 % en année
pleine
or les estimations de l'insee et de la
banque de france table sur une baisse de
35% de la production et nous savons
aujourd'hui que le chômage partiel
touchent déjà 44,5 % de l'emploi salarié
quant à la productivité du travail de
ceux qui travaillent toujours par
exemple en télétravail
elle a visiblement pas mal baissé alors
il faut regarder d'autres estimations
comme celles qui sont faites par la
banque italienne unicredit ou celles qui
ont été faites dans mon propre
laboratoire leucémiques etc
ces différentes estimations indiquent
tout des pertes plus importantes
d'autant plus que l'économie tournera au
ralenti pendant encore plusieurs mois
après la date de déconfinement autrement
dit la récession pour 2020 risque d'être
plus proche de 10% que de 8%
alors vous me l'aviez déjà dire la
semaine dernière effectivement mais cela
aura évidemment des conséquences
budgétaires
lewis était inévitable c'était
inévitable
d'ailleurs bruno le maire a reconnu que
le gouvernement avait fait le choix de
s'endetter pour sauver l'économie
mais en l'état actuel j'ai craint que
l'on continue de sous-estimer les
conséquences de ce choix
nous avons aussi travaillé sur cette
question oc me et aux dépenses
nécessaires pour soutenir les
entreprises et ces dépenses ne cesse
d'augmenter
60 milliards puis 100 milliards puis 110
milliards et bien vont s'ajouter des
pertes importantes liées à la baisse
d'activité si l'on ajoute que le déficit
qui était déjà inscrit dans la loi de
finances pour 2020 était d'environ à 54
milliards et bien on arrive à un déficit
total pour 2020 d'environ 300 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire à peu près très et
demi pour cent du pib
alors jacques le patron du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux a provoqué une
polémique en disant qu'il faudrait
travailler plus après le déconfinement
la banque de france elle a parlé d'
austérité du fait de l'ampleur de la
dette publique le monde d'après
verra-t-il un retour à l'austérité des
ventes d'avant et c'est vrai le
président du medef et celui de lui et
même vous savez la fédération patronale
de la métallurgie ont choqué en
demandant un assouplissement des règles
sur le temps de travail et sur les
congés payés jusqu'à la fin de 2021
alors devant la polémique qui a été
causé par leurs propos ils ont reculé
et puis il ya ce qu'a déclaré la banque
de france et la banque de france a
indiqué que l'ampleur de l'endettement
conduirait à des sacrifices à l'avenir
prenant ainsi le contre-pied de ce que
font et de ce que disent bien sûr les
autres banques centrales
alors est-ce que ça annonce le retour de
l'austérité pour l'après épidémie eh
bien on voit que sur ce point
malheureusement la france semble
toujours fidèle à une orthodoxie
monétaire et fiscale que d'autres pays
semblent bien avoir quant à eux
abandonnées alors justement jacques
comment les autres pays dont vous faites
allusion réa j'estime sont ces questions
alors stéphanie il est très intéressant
de voir que bien des tabous en fait on
sautait à l'étranger alors prenons le
cas des états unis la fed la réserve
fédérale
rachel désormais massivement les dettes
privées y compris d'ailleurs les
mauvaises et les bêtes publique du
gouvernement afin d'éviter bien sûr que
l'économie ne coule
elle annonce ainsi des rachats jusqu'à
2300 milliards de dollars autrement dit
2 3 trillions de dollars c'est une somme
qu'il faut comparer avec le programme de
la banque centrale européenne pour
fameux programme ppp qui lui plafonne à
1000 milliards d'euros
mais le plus intéressant c'est ce qui se
passe au royaume uni les autorités
prévoient là bas une baisse de 12 à 13%
du pib' ce qui est d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus réaliste que les prévisions de
bruno le maire alors face à cela la
banque d'angleterre là où les dés comme
on l'appelle a annoncé qu'elle
financerait directement le gouvernement
autrement dit qu'elle rachèterait
directement les dettes émises par le
trésor
et cela sans passer par l'intermédiaire
des banques privées c'est une véritable
révolution car les ré les rachats qui
était d'ailleurs couramment pratiqué
jusqu'au début des années 70 ont été par
la suite interdite et cette interdiction
figure même dans la charte de la banque
centrale européenne alors mes jacques à
qu'est ce que cela nous dit sur le monde
d'après
allemands et bien stéphanie que ce monde
d'après en tous les cas pour les autres
pays que la france pourrait être
effectivement bien différent du monde
avant on comprend bien que les
principales économies sont en train de
connaître un choc qui est aujourd'hui
bien supérieur à la crise de 2008 2009
un choc qui n'est en réalité comparable
qu'à celui de la crise de 1929 et de la
grande dépression qui en a suivi il donc
pas étonnant que les gouvernements
regardent désormais les mesures qui ont
été appliqués à l'époque où à partir de
si l'on veulent encore regarder la
france de l'après guerre alors jacquat
n'est ce pas finalement aussi ce
qu'annonce d'une certaine manière le
discours d' emmanuel macron vous avez
tout à fait raison
et de ce point de vue ni de ce point de
vue la fin de l'allocution d'emmanuel
macron était très intéressant quand le
président dit notre monde sans doute se
fragmentera quand il parle aussi de
repartir une indépendance agricole
sanitaire industrielles et
technologiques françaises
eh bien on croirait entendre le général
de gaulle mais aussi d'ailleurs les
hommes politiques de la quatrième
république comme par exemple pierre
mendès france ou guy mollet quand le
président rappelle les mots de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen vous savez les distinctions
sociales ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune
il mobilise des symboles de notre
histoire qui sont effectivement très
fort enfin quand il dit à la fin de son
discours il nous faudra bâtir une
stratégie où nous retrouverons le temps
long la possibilité de planifier vous
avez bien entendu la possibilité de
planifier et bien on croirait entendre
du jean luc mélenchon dont le texte
alors mon peut-on croire jacques peuvent
ton pardon on le croire sur parole ces
mots n'ont ils pas été prononcé
simplement pour faire un petit peu
passer la pilule d'un confinement
prolongée jusqu'au 11 mai bien sûr c'est
fini on peut avoir des doutes
après tout selon la phrase attribuée à
jacques chirac
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
les écoutent
mais les réalités de l'économie mondiale
après l'épidémie vont elles aussi
s'imposer à emmanuel macron les chaînes
de production internationalisé dans la
mondialisation sont aujourd'hui
considérés comme beaucoup trop fragiles
en cas de perturbations majeures comme
celle que nous connaissons
il faudra donc nécessairement
relocaliser de même la pénurie de
masques de tests de médicaments de
respirateurs que nous connaissons montre
aussi que l'on ne peut plus dépendre
exclusivement des importations il faudra
donc rebâtir un outil de production
nationale et l'industrie
réindustrialiser la france et cela il
faut tout de suite le dire ne sera pas
possible sans un minimum de
protectionnisme alors pour faire tout
cela il faudra bien s'émanciper de
nombreuses règles et directives de
l'union européenne
retrouvez aussi notre souveraineté
monétaire effectivement mettre en oeuvre
une forme de planification stratégique
ces mesures sont les conséquences de la
démondialisation qui est aujourd'hui en
marche
si on peut dire en conclusion jacques
selon-vous emmanuel macron saura-t-il et
sortons pourra-t-il s'adapter à ce
nouveau monde
oui il a dit qu'il devrait se réinventer
et c'est une excellente question que
vous posez c'est fanny parce que pour
ceux là pour justement se réinventer il
lui faudrait mettre ses bottes dans les
pas de l'opposition la plus radicale
celle qui va de mélenchon à marine le
pen
et ça ça semble très peu vraisemblable
à tout le moins emmanuel macron a d'une
certaine façon et il fait il faut bien
le dire dans son discours légitimer les
propos de ses opposants les plus
radicaux
avec ce discours il a aussi suscité des
espoirs immenses et pas seulement quand
à l'annoncé d'une date de déconfinement
11 mai et naturellement il sera jugé sur
pièce merci jacques évidemment toujours
des réflexions qui nous font analyser
mieux la situation et nous font nous
poser encore plus de questions merci à
vous